[Musique]
cette semaine a été très agréable donc
j'étais logé à djibouti et donc voilà
donc petite balade aussi autour
confluent de l'allier de la loire rendu
des beaux paysages
la douceur de vivre se prendre la tête
ça s'est bien passé on a été plutôt un
modèle du coi touristes donc on a pris
le temps de bien profiter visiter même
si on vit pas en centre-ville
on n'a pas comme ça de grands espaces de
brengues furini donc ç'a changé et ça
faisait du bien d'être d'être au vert la
viande d'origine
voilà donc vraiment tout s'est bien
passé on est quelqu'un nous sommes des
personnes ou la tranquillité est mature
donc honnêtement
[Musique]
pour l'instant j'ai pas donc j'ai pas de
plan définitif pour l'avenir donc je
part entière fait pas je comptais pas
bien sceller définitivement je sais pas
si on doit déménager dans la nièvre
je pense qu'il nous faudrait un autre
séjour peut-être que tous les deux pour
pour regarder du coup plutôt le côté
immobilier les écoles tous dangereux
ouais le fait qu'ils payent l'armement
c'est pas quelque chose qui me dérange
particulièrement aux partir du moment où
venir à nos besoins on puisse avoir une
zone de commerces par exemple au risque
c'est le réseau là c'est de pouvoir
communiquer avec l'extérieur ça peut
être quand même en en gros freins à
l'installation
malheureusement ceux qui pêchent souvent
dans la nef c'est le travail les
apprenants machine en batik et
honnêtement a pas trouvé sur une grande
ville c'est souvent plus compliqué le
set de pas avoir quand même grande ville
dans laquelle on nous promet d'avoir des
loisirs des des sorties je pense que ce
genre de choses ça pourrait peut-être
nous manquer c'est un petit peu isolé
quand même